so that we can Safeguard the
communication well
you can take a minute break yourself of
course if you wish
okay chick chick do you have
some now see check check the bus it's
okay but perfect
yeah okay dear friends uh ready for our
next pond in the agenda
give you a couple of of seconds
take your seeds
in these days we
have to be aware that it's one year
that Masha amini at the age of 22
was murdered
in the presence of this
Iranian regime for what reason
for nothing
because she was purely adjusting her
well
that showed the face the brutal face
of
an illiberal regime
and cause the Iranian Society
to engage itself in protests taking the
streams of Iran's towns and villages
with the motto women life freedom
we saw
the reaction of a regime that couldn't
handle
Democratic protests
that couldn't handle and was not willing
to handle
Democratic freedoms
and reacted
by the abuse of Human Rights
more than 500 people were killed over 20
000 arrested tortured
and maltreated by the security forces
death sentences increased rapidly
where not only issued
but also
executed the European Parliament in our
subcommittee have reacted
of course to add in several occasions
already in October 22 we condemned the
systematic violence
we had resolutions in January in last
March calling on the European
institutions
to react rigidly to defend human rights
we were talking at the end of April in
Geneva
with the members of the independent
International fact-finding mission
established by the U.N Human Rights
Council
and the U.N special operator
Mr Raymond whom we have the pleasure to
hearing very soon here in our committee
we organized a full week with other
committees and institutions in the
European Parliament together of
solidarity with the Iran people
and also organized exchanges of views on
International level to support the
initiative
of
the world's Democratic family to defend
freedom and democracy
let me conclude
with an eye on the recent ongoings
in Iran a regime that suppresses its
people
poisons and kills its children
and take it as a symbol
hinders a father to visit the grave of
his daughter
put him in prison
because he wanted to visit the grave
at one year's memory of the murdering of
his daughter as a system like that is
done
it is lost all the legitimacy that you
need to keep up your government in a
sustainable way
not only legitimacy that is finished
and let us also say we know the day will
come
in this Spirit we would like to have our
meeting today
supporting
the Freedom Fighters
of this country supporting all those who
take high risks
to defend
their Liberty
to stand up and to speak out
we are more than happy to have with us
today
man I mentioned it already U.N special
repertoire on the situation of human
rights in Iran Gilda sahibi journalist
and author and expert on the situation
in the Middle East
and azade Kian sociologist and expert on
Iran and women's right
University Paris City
all three of them will communicate with
us in hybrid mode will be online
our apologies the U.N Special Report has
to leave after our conversation
because the ongoing in Geneva require
him to go to the next meeting so please
my apologies to Gilda and to us a day
that we once we have heard Mr Raymond we
immediately go in and exchange questions
and answers and afterwards here our
representatives
sahibi and Kian and enter into a second
round of conversation now let me ask Mr
Raymond whether he is connected with us
I would be pleased to see that
hi again we met already in Geneva and we
are more than happy to having you here
with us Mr Raymond on behalf of your
very specific and important function
could you perhaps for some eight minutes
uh give you your take on the current
situation
thank you very much chair uh thank you
for this generous invitation
um I hope that I'm Audible and I'm
visible to all colleagues and
participants in this very important
meeting
uh I begin by thanking the European
Parliament uh the subcommittee on human
rights for once again giving me an
opportunity to speak directly to you I'm
very grateful and I will
um make good use of the time that has
been generously allocated uh to to me by
yourself
as has been mentioned by the chair since
September 2022
the brave people of Iran have been
facing the worst forms of violations of
human rights
ethnic linguistic and religious
minorities continue to suffer from
systematic and systemic persecution
targeting and harassment
women and girls of Iran are targeted
with the most serious assault on the
fundamental human rights and human
dignity
the morality police the cause of much
detestation and aggravation
has lately been redeployed with women
and girls being confronted detained and
harassed
these policies are intended to further
violate women's rights and the dignity
by attempts to enforce
the hijab
as you're aware the death in custody of
the morality police of Gina masamine on
16th of September 2022
Unleashed one of the strongest waves of
protests in civil unrest Iran has seen
during the past four decades
she was arrested
for allegedly failing to comply with the
Iran's strict rules on women's stress by
varying an improper hijab
the death and custody of Miss amini is
unfortunately a tragic reflection of the
violence against girls and women of Iran
in her case there are also clear
implications with an ethnic and
religious dimension
however the law of enforcedure and the
manner of its enforcement by state
authorities is emblematic of violence
brutality and the violation of
fundamental human rights and human
dignity of girls and women of the
country
death resulted in spontaneous protests
which were led by women and the Youth of
Iran
under the banner of Zan Zindagi Azadi
which means women life freedom
these protests quickly transformed into
Nationwide protests spreading to 160
cities
and in 31 provinces of Iran with with
people from every Community girls women
boys men and children and people from
all ethnic and religious and linguistic
backgrounds joining these protests
unfortunately there has been a brutal
response
um of the Iranian authorities towards
these protests
it is estimated that the use of lethal
Force by Security Forces has led to the
deaths of at least 537 persons including
at least 68 children
Iranian authorities tried to shut down
all avenues of freedom of expression
disrupting internet and censoring social
media platforms
I am deeply Disturbed at the reports of
threats arrests and imprisonment of
journalists for their critical and
independent reporting including in the
context of the protests and indeed the
subsequent suspected School poisonings
affecting the health of thousands of
school girls
I'm absolutely horrified shocked and
outraged that despite appeals by the
International Community
including by my own mandate
Iranian authorities of thus far executed
at least Seven Persons associated with
protests after arbitrary summary and
Sham trials which violated the right to
Fair trial and due process rights
these summary executions are the symbol
of a state ready to use all means to
instill fair and to quash protests I'm
very concerned that several other
individuals currently face charges that
carry the death penalty
I am alarmed at the reports of targeting
and victimization and persecution of
ethnic linguistic and religious
minorities
it was extremely tragic to note that
ethnic and religious minorities have
suffered Decades of systemic and
systematic discrimination and
persecution
have been disproportionately impacted in
the current wave of repression led by
and brought upon by the Iranian
authorities
the Iranian authorities have
unfortunately also weaponized the death
penalty as an instrument of fear and
repression
this includes a disproportionate
execution of ethnic and religious
minority prisoners as well as an as well
as an alarming number of persons
executed on drug related offenses
my report to the Human Rights Council
last year in March that is March 2022
and March 2023 have firmly established
my conclusions that there is an absence
of accountability for serious human
rights violations and for crimes and
international law within the political
constitutional and legal system of Iran
in my view the scale and gravity of the
violations committed by the Iranian
authorities especially since the death
of Miss amini points to the possible
Commission of international crimes
notably the crimes against humanity of
murder imprisonment and false
disappearances torture rape and sexual
violence and persecution
and so what about any investigations and
establishing accountability for serious
violations of human rights in Iran
unfortunately as I pointed out none of
the investigations or attempts to
establish accountability has taken place
in the country
there has been a governmental failure to
conduct any independent impartial and
transparent investigations into the
murderous acts which includes the murder
of Gina masamini but the over 500
persons including children
there is no accountability for these
murderous acts these killings and
brutality and the perpetrators have not
been held accountable
instead there is continuing repression
harassment and Detention of Human Rights
Defenders lawyers journalists and
students which has increased in the past
few months family members of individuals
that were executed in connection with
the protests were summoned to court or
detained in Iran for asking for justice
also in the past few weeks the
authorities have detained dozens of
Human Rights defenders in what appears
to be a concerted effort to Cosh any
protests in advance of the anniversary
of the September 2022 death of misamini
which had as you have just been told
triggered the Nationwide demonstrations
regrettably
the authorities have prevented masam in
his family for commemorating the
anniversary of her death this was so
tragic and so painful
there are also reports of sporadic
protests in the country over the over
the weekend amid very heavy presence of
police and security forces all across
Iran and I am deeply concerned at the
current
ongoing situation and what it could
develop into because the state is
determined to use brutality and to
repress the people of Iran I end here
and I would be happy to take any
questions from you thank you very much
thank you so much special about uh Mr
Raymond we are now proceeding as follows
we will have one speaker per group
go back to you for a response we know
that you have to see then the Human
Rights Council which you have to attend
and I will bring in Gilda and azadeh to
address us for further discussions and
our first speaker is David Liga for the
PPE
thank you so much chair and thank you so
much Mr Raymond for taking the time to
having this discussion with us today I
mean it's extremely important that we
don't forget or keep quiet about the
situation one year after Miss amini was
so brutally murdered by the regime as he
said because she wore the hijab the
wrong way and we all know that the
protests are still going on and that the
people of Iran have had enough and I
must say that I am appalled by the
Iranian regime's ongoing Crackdown on
demonstrators in Iran who are fighting
for their freedom and even for their
lives and we cannot forget performing
this Crackdown by the Iranian regime is
none other than the Iranian
revolutionary guard corpse or the irgc
and this is the same same group that we
I and others have called for a terrorist
designation of during several occasions
and so as this Parliament repeatedly
done
I think that it's Frankly Speaking
almost hypocritical for the EU to say
that we stand with the women of Iran but
then not designating the irgc as
terrorists but my my two questions to
you are do you see any problems having
an Iranian regime representative chair
of the human you and Human Rights
Council social Forum in November this
year while the decision has been
criticized by several countries and also
while the unhrc is by themselves
investigating the regime's violations
and also the final one while searching
around and preparing this I couldn't
find any U.N statements or press
releases regarding the irgc's Crackdown
on the protests in the aftermath of the
killing has the U.N made any and if not
why
thank you so much thanks David for the
yes indeed did Marcus
thank you very much for your
presentation first of all I would like
to underline this that this is a regime
which is acting against its own citizens
there is no doubt about this
this regime is still uh
um doing a really cool job still the
death penalty
is
put in place and this regime committed
crimes against humanity and still we
have
a lot of cases of public executions and
this is not acceptable for all civil and
Democratic societies and they are
committing as you have mentioned already
human crimes and so for me the question
what can we do
to make those people accountable what
they are doing to oppress their own
citizens and for me as my colleague
David legard has mentioned we in the
European Parliament are demanding that
the Revolutionary guard must be put on
the terrorist I think this must be a
clear signal we demand this in the
European Parliament and I would like to
know how you would assess this and
last but not least we have to keep in
mind that this regime is not only a
misogynistic regime it is an
anti-semitic regime and it wants to
develop nuclear weapons with the goal to
these to destroy Israel and I would like
to know how you what your opinion is on
this thank you
foreign
thank you chairman thank you very much a
reporter for your remarks
a year on from the assassination of a
mass the situation is still extremely
complex in Iran in August 2023
a former Elite Guard from the guardian
of the revolution
had been brought before the courts by
two ngos for torture
but he's now the president of the
Iranian Olympic paralympic Committee and
he actually obtained a visa to travel to
France for the Olympic Games in 2024.
how is this possible it's totally
unacceptable in my view
are you in touch with the council
to ensure that that list of people in
the sanctions from the EU for human
rights violations is being updated
and I have a question on now on what we
can do the greens here in this house had
called on member states to step up when
it came to opening the borders to people
who were being persecuted that's one way
of supporting the movement in Iran
do you share the view that the EU and
the member states could be doing much
more when it comes to providing
protection and welcoming as well as
preventing humanitarian visas to those
who seek these visas from Iran thank you
since all of our colleagues were
questioning very very disciplined we can
have a quick second round a very quick
second round and the first is
also nacho for the snd channels
yes thank you uh I I believe I will be
very short uh my two president
colleagues they asked the the same
questions what we can do really how we
can change this situation how which
influence we can have on uh on the
situation of Iranian women girls
and Iranian people thank you
thank you Nacho please yeah I have a
very simple question now we are we're
having in many TV broadcasts a lot of
programs about the anniversary of
Civilian one of them I think is BBC
there was a portraying of the resistance
of the women to the bail
same thing is more or less was the same
world there are more and more women not
pale on the street what means that this
is kind of flexibility is only the
resistance what is the policy it the
same in big cities than in rural areas
could you have please have an an inside
this situation thank you
okay so far and now we go immediately
back to Rabbit reman our U.N special
operator for a response to the questions
from our colleagues
yes thank you chair
now I will try to be as precise and
brief as is possible
um some very important questions have
been raised
uh so let me first begin by saying on
the issue of um of the women and girls
on Iran you see
um what I say that what's happening in
Iran is not simply discrimination of
persecution of women and girls it is
effectively gender apartheid you see if
you look at the policies and the way
women are humiliating degrading and
persecuted we must make a point to say
that this is unacceptable all of us all
men and women of the world people from
all religions including Muslim men and
women
must regard this policy of enforced
hijab unacceptable and call this form of
repression of women in a country like
Iran but also Afghanistan this kind of
treatment must be established as gender
apartheid
um a related point is uh is on the issue
of uh you know because women and girls
in Iran have stood up uh in many parts
of the country effectively this is a
civil disobedience movement the regime
is making new laws more repressive than
ever before but simply because the women
of girls women and girls of Iran are so
brave they do not accept it anymore so
we have to support uh all of these Brave
women and girls uh in in not following
an unjust unnatural and repressive law
so that's that's one point
um on the broader issue of what we
should do I believe that it's very
important that we support the people of
Iran in whatever way shape or form we
can in their Democratic aspirations
because they are democratic people they
want to have the right to to determine
in their own destiny and the important
element is that we have also got to be
honest with ourselves you see
um in in my own view I think we have to
make a decision do we prioritize human
rights or do we uh work on the on the
basis of some kind of a negotiated
settlement with an oppressive
authoritarian dictatorial regime which
has in my view committed gross
violations of human rights law including
crimes against humanity so it is very
important for this August Forum to make
a decision to to say to the world to
tell the European Parliament that human
rights must be our priority they must
not we must not make any deals we must
not negotiate with a murderous regime
and therefore we must support the people
of Iran and that connects to several
other issues that has been raised about
the position of irdc uh now this is up
to individual member states and this is
up to the European Parliament to make a
decision they have all of the evidence
that is available and my offices are
there and so are many other forms of
evidence testimonies and documentation
to for them to to realize the extent of
murderous acts that have been committed
and are being committed by the irgc so
we have to make a decision as to where
we see the place of human rights in any
form of discussions with Iran and the
same applies to the social Forum you
know having a social Forum where Iran
has a presidency and I would urge member
states and the European uh Parliament to
reach out to the human Rights Council
and to the president of the Human Rights
Council to reflect their disappointment
and to say well uh this is not something
that we would want Iran to be leading up
to and therefore this decision must be
reconsidered I end here but I'd be happy
to take any further supplementary
questions thank you
Mr Raymond we are totally happy that you
are with us today this is the clear
language this is the clear language we
know from you
and we appreciate that a lot we wish you
courage and success
because we need that the people of Iran
need that and you are in a key position
where you really are ready and this is
what we hear whenever we are talking to
you
to deliver properly at the very best
I can say for the European Parliament we
have made up our mind the European
Parliament has taken its decision
we have
been clear on the way in which the
Revolutionary God should be treated
because we were saying in our
resolutions
it should be that way because our
argument is
look
if those guys are not to be put on the
list of terrorists groups who would you
like to put on that list
and we are waiting the member states to
act
according to the resolutions of the
European Parliament this is the
situation today we would wish that all
institutions would have the clear
language that you have and that the
European Parliament have and we will
walk towards that direction please allow
me now to bring in our guests
um from uh the widest spectrum of those
who can have a huge impact on this
situation that is killed as a she's
a journalist and author and expert of
our situation in the of the women in
Iran and azade Kian a sociologist from
Paris
thanks for your patience dear guests and
we are looking forward you have already
realized that the questions of my
colleagues concentrate only not only on
the analysis what is the situation like
what what is your take what are the the
recent developments but it's also
focusing what can be done and what can
we do within the European institutions
to support
the movement for freedom and democracy
can I ask whether we have killed asahibi
with us
welcome to us and to our discussion
today and please take the floor for
eight minutes and then right after you I
will invite asada and open for new
rounds of conversation with my
colleagues
you to the subcommitt human rights and
it was very interesting also to listen
to Mr rehman about his um
his thoughts and and how he sees the
situation at the moment
um I would like to tell you a bit about
the current situation because I've been
in touch with a lot of people in Iran in
the past week ahead of the protest but
also after
and then I would like to say some things
about the politics European politics
um
so what I can say from people in Iran
right now before the protests
there were some positive things and some
negative things
so what is positive is that people tell
me within this past year
the people of Iran have really come
together and we have heard some of that
because the this Iranian regime what it
does best is to divide people and it's
been doing that for 44 years and in this
past year because also because
Kurdish and
the ethnic minorities are and have been
suppressed
way more than even the the rest of
society and of the of the people and
there has never really been this feeling
of we belong together but this past year
really has brought people together they
tell me that they walk on the streets
and they smile at each other people they
don't know because there is a feeling of
the only chance that we have is if we
walk together if we fight together and
that is something that has changed
something else that has changed in this
past year is this the position basically
of women in this country because
um women have been at the Forefront of
this protest it's not only been women
it's been men the lgbtiq community has
also gained a lot of visibility in this
past year
and still women have held the flag as
one protester told me he he told me that
he grew up in this
and basically party our key where he
learned that men have to protect women
and you know just be men basically and
he said and then he was on the streets
in this during these protests and he saw
these young women and girls
incredibly strong and and just set on
what they want their freedom and
equality and he said I realized the only
thing that I can do is to support them
and they're the one who are leading us
and so uh one woman told me that she
feels like women are more respected
um and a lot of people in Iran have
realized that the only way that this
regime is going to fall is by women life
freedom because
the hatred towards women towards
minorities is the basis and the
foundation of this government and of
this regime so the way to free to be
free from this regime will be through
the liberation of exactly these groups
and I think a lot of people have have
come to understand this and this is the
strength behind this movement
what's
um have not been negative and that's
what I heard from all of them everyone I
talked to last in the past couple of
weeks is the anger towards especially
the West
one person he had been in in a torture
cell in the fall
in one of these clandestine torture
sites that are all around the country
um and he told me and he raised his
voice he was very emotional he said you
know you you you people you stood in
parliaments you cut your hair you talked
and you talked
what have you actually done
and I did not have an answer because
and and I am aware that the European
Parliament of course has been way
stronger
um in their in their demands and I also
think in their analysis towards what's
happening in Iran
and yet of course it is the member
states and the governments of the
European countries that are going to
determine how they act towards Iran
and one thing that is missing in this
um in their policies is Unity we see
this very very clearly when it comes to
political prisoners
European political prisoners
so in the country where I am based in
Germany
the government doesn't even call them
political prisoners and they don't
publicly demand the release of them
there are at least two Germans in Iran
in prison
German Iranians actually
and there have been prisoner swaps the
one terrorist who was sentenced to 20
years in prison in Belgium he was freed
for a Belgium Citizen and part of this
deal were also Irish French and danish
citizens
and the Iranian regime really knows how
to use this
this lack of unity in inside of the
European Union because
as I said the thing that this regime
does best is divide and the only chance
also the European Union has is if
they're United
and I think as with with all uh or many
many issues in the European unions there
are member states
that do not care a lot about human
rights about Justice
about a fair justice system trials
accountability everything that we heard
that is missing in Iran
and
what I think is that this is nothing
that is Gonna Change quickly
but I think the way the European Union
has behaved and acted in this year of
protest in Iran
is
could be
the chance to start to change this way
of policies of having policies because
and we just heard it and I I just want
to I'm a political analyst and I want to
um just make clear that I don't think
what we just heard from Mr rehman that
we need to put human rights in the
center of everything is naive or not
strategic I think that's the only way
that strategy works because we've seen
that in Russia with Russia if if the
European Union had reacted with
sanctions in 2015 when Russia attacked
Syria
in the same way that they are now
attacking Ukraine
the chance of Russia doing that again in
Ukraine I think would have been smaller
and I think if the European union
doesn't really start working on putting
human rights in the center of every
single policy
this is this whole situation is going to
get worse and worse and not only in Iran
but we see it in Iran now because this
is the kind of Freedom Movement and
equality movement that politicians in
the west and the European Union ask for
in every speech that they give
there are people and I talk to them
every day who know what equality is they
know what freedom is and they know what
democracy is and they know that they as
every single other person on this planet
deserve that
and they are dying for this I've talked
to 17 year olds 18 year olds who say I
am willing to die for the Next
Generation to be free
and I don't think there is a stronger
statement
to make clear how serious these people
are
and if the European Union who has won
the the Nobel Prize
which is not deserved
this was the last year that shows the
policies at the at the borders of the
urban Union
if they really are serious about
caring for human rights and what else is
there to care about because we are all
humans it is about humans it is about
children it is about families women
lgbtiq people
then this is not this is going to cause
so many more problems
for the rest of anything that is going
to come we all again we see that in
Ukraine the global South they tell us
you know our problems are not yours but
now your problems are supposed to be
ours and they they have a point because
this is I think this is now
Iran for me is a wake-up call because
European Union has not been able to
support the Iranian people in their
strive for freedom
and if the European union doesn't see
this as a wake-up call to put up
structures so that human rights is not
optional but
they have to be in the center and this
is not something that's going to happen
tomorrow that's going to take time this
is going to take years because it's a
changing of Minds changing of structures
but it needs to start at some point
and I think this could be a start and
without Unity
it is going to be very difficult not
only towards the Iranian regime
but towards any authoritarian regime in
the world
thank you
thank you so much Gilda
I would like to give you colleagues a
technical information our next guest
asada Kian has some technical problems
to be connected
so I would like to open the floor
to discuss the contribution of Gilda
and hope she can stay with us for the
discussion Gilda you
I do not know whether you are aware of
how important
your contribution is to our debate
and we are serious be the subcommittee
of human rights are extremely serious
of your analysis and what you say what
you have to say and what you underscore
in your statement the good and the bad
we heard both
and I'm pretty sure that we are ready to
discussing that my first question is
from the PPE side who would like to take
the floor
please Leopold
thank you Gilda for your
time and insight on on this tragedy
my question is
in some of your Awards the
you seem to to have discovered some
resentment towards the West
for not
being
uh
active enough I would say in this
in the suffering of the of the people of
Iran
my question is
is anyone doing anything on the
international court of justice to bring
about some justice into very particular
persons that are identified by
committing the crimes themselves
thank you
and the next speaker comes from the
Socialists and Democrats did Marcus
thank you very much for your
presentation Gilda and
um
our solidarity is with the movement in
Iran with a revolutionary movement and I
think we must do more here in the
European Parliament and especially the
European Union European Council to
overthrow this Mula regime
and
you have mentioned that it is very
important that the opposition must be
United I would like to know
how would you assess the social economic
situation in your country and which role
trade unions are playing I think one of
the most important thing is if you want
to get rid of this regime the question
is on the table how is it possible to
organize a general strike or something
like this and I would like to know from
you how you would assess this and the
second question is
um probably some protesters are
desperate and probably they are leading
the country
is this a development at the moment
our next speaker is munir
um
a few words only so thank you first of
all for your
statements
uh we do read a lot about these matters
but hearing from you personally is much
more meaningful I have a question
what can we do
in concrete terms to help you do you
have any specific precise demands from
MEPS how can we support you that's my
question thank you
it was munir for the European greens and
now we have Isabel from the PPE
Mercy
thank you
it was very moving to listen to you
I would also like to thank the special
reporter
for their work now a year ago in the
very beginning of
this
um
occurrence a colleague had said that she
was hesitant as to to what extent we
should support
action in this realm because of what had
happened the time before
the results
of former help had been murder prison
sentences and the like and we did not
achieve the results that we had aimed
for
and now we can see that the movement as
you have yourself described is still
very alive and I think that is admirable
it is uh quite surprising in fact to see
to what extent uh people can sacrifice
so much
to reach its aims
this however has been going on for a
while and uh
what do you think
the few will be held in the future and
then I would like to support my
colleague in this question as to what
concrete action we can take to support
you thank you
okay I hear that we now have azade with
us she's connected but allow me because
for systematic reasons that we continue
now in this speaking order for the
colleagues concluding by giving back the
flaw to Gilda to respond to this
conversation then we are going to hear
azade Kian we have a new other day and
have a new round of of conversation
David Liga
thank you chair and thank you so much Mr
Happy for for joining us it was very
hard to think of questions when you were
so Crystal Clear in all your
interventions so thank you for that I I
do have some thoughts and are a bit
curious on your thoughts regarding the
Iranian diaspora how are they working
and helping and how can we in better
ways help them because
sometimes it's hard to know who to reach
out to and how
so your thoughts on the how joint they
are in their organization and what we
can do to support them would be
interesting to hear more about thank you
and finally I cannot resist the
challenge to us ask a question myself
Gilda
the political analysts we are talking to
that is two challenges to miss the point
to to ask you on three different
dimensions uh
we get the sense of belonging that was
the positive part of your report
where people feel part of a society that
would like to become free
and that is amazing to to hear about
that and and to seeing that uh but we
also listen to the bad things to the bad
developments and of course it's very
fast it's very important to hear also
about the disappointment of uh what you
call the West because it's including the
European Union and its institution let
me
for that reason and this is not an
apology this is not an excuse because I
immediately
understand what you mean and I know that
you are right and that those who say
that are right in many many respects but
on behalf of my colleagues many of us
here in the European Parliament
as well as in National parliaments took
the decision on a totally individual in
individual track
to commit themselves to sponsorships for
political prisoners in Iran
in my case and that is is the
work of my colleagues in my office we
were happy enough to receive a tortured
prisoner in Germany three days ago to
become a new citizen of Germany you have
no idea how happy my team is how how
happy all the other colleagues are who
have similar successes
but this is not an answer
and this is not an excuse
because that is goes without saying but
everybody should do who has some
influence
but we try and let me also ask on the on
the institutional and also on the
Strategic dimension of the ACT you say
what we try to do as a subcommittee of
Human Rights we try to maneuver the
European Parliament and we were quite
successfully doing that because our
resolutions are clear
we have a clear-cut majority
to put the revolution card on the
terrorist list and we have clear-cut
positions not to doing the wrong
compromises in dealing with the regime
but we lack
obviously the consent of the member
states because the member states are not
doing what they can do
and you mentioned that for a member
state which you know very well
uh me too
so
the the political question is on the
institutional layer
what can we do
to promote a political
discourse in Our member states
which enables us within the European
institutions to be more clear more
decisive
more proactive and supporting
those who are victims but also who are
so courageously demanding their freedom
in the Iran
and the last element that is what we
discussed on the occasion of natural
amours
annual report on the situation of Human
Rights earlier to this point today in
the agenda we see
the reshuffling of power structures on
the globe we see the enlargement of the
bricks
by members like the Iran the Saudis and
others extremely uh
human rights friendly regimes yeah
and we ask ourselves how come
that dedicated democracies like Brazil
or like South Africa who have suffered
themselves from suppression
are lining up with these kind of
countries for common interests to form
whatever they call it a block or a group
of Interest
shared interests or whatever
and what do you think as a political
analyst what do you think the European
reaction will be of course the Europeans
will try institutionally to renegotiate
with countries
in reach to defend somehow what they
think is about democracy and freedom etc
etc and here
you're
demand to put human rights in the center
of everything this is the conviction of
our colleagues here in the human rights
subcommittee we would subscribe
immediately to what you are saying
but it's not too easy it's not too easy
to make it
strategically key
in the next five or ten years because
this shifting power structure
questions also the way
we will not give in one centimeter but
it questions also the way in which we
talk about human rights in which we try
to implement human rights
and in which we fight
for those who are our allies and most of
the time victims in autocratic uh
regimes what is your take on that
because it's it's too interesting what
you are saying so although I like to
question further
thank you so much thank you so much for
uh for your question I'm gonna try to
because it's a lot of them I'm gonna try
to go through all of them briefly and
let me just because we didn't actually
uh didn't talk about the um region and
and the and the foreign policy
perspective because I think that is a
very interesting point you mentioned the
the brics plus uh Iran is is has joined
with Saudi Arabia and other states
and I think it's important to know when
it comes to Iran that Iran would not
have joined brics
plus warranted for this political
situation inside of the country because
the Iranian regime has never been so
shaken to their core in these 44 years
and that is very important to know this
is why they prepared so massively for
this anniversary we had on Saturday
there were military all over the country
everywhere and they will not be able to
hold that up forever so people are going
to wait for the military to disappear
and then I think they're going to
protest again
but I'm going to say a few words about
the prospects
um and also you you know that um Saudi
Arabia is number one enemy to Iran to
the Iran regime
it is up there with Israel so taking the
step of of
um of taking up diplomatic relations
again with Saudi Arabia also something
this regime would not have done if it
wasn't in a fragile state and it is
don't get me wrong it it really really
is there have been leaks internal leaks
that showed how afraid
the regime has been and they still are
if they weren't they wouldn't have put
up this incredible military presence in
in the whole country
so this is something to know
um that they so what the Iranian regime
is scared of is that it's going to
implode because as you know the people
don't have weapons so it's not gonna
well it's not going to happen that you
know there's going to be like a Civil
War and then the people win or the
regime wins or whatever that's not how
it works the only way for this regime in
my opinion to fall if is if its
followers leave
this government and this regime they
they withdraw their support I kind of I
see it as like a an onion and yet the
different layers of of followers and
it's gonna have to dissolve that's how
it's gonna
um lose that's how it's gonna fall
and that also goes to the question what
can what can uh we do what can you do I
think because of this
um dynamics of
um having to see the regime basically
implode is putting attention on what is
going on in Iran and European Parliament
has been doing that a lot this past year
because
the only thing that's going to keep
people from from keep supporting this
regime is their fear of being prosecuted
or of even being killed at some point by
its own people
because people and they say it's about
10 to 15 of the population
they support the regime because the
regime gives them three things money
power and security
and when these three things are not
given to them anymore then they're not
going to support them anymore and this
is what the regime is scared of
and what has changed in this past year
is that we have finally looked into what
has been happening in Iran for 44 years
nothing of what has been happening in
this past year is new
Amnesty International has given out
yearly and annual reports about exactly
these same things that Mr Raymond has
been describing
but for the first time in Iranian in the
history of the Islamic Republic
we have seen the pictures of children
that have been killed and and raped and
women that have been imprisoned and
beaten up that's that was the first time
and that was the dangerous thing so you
mentioned the sponsorships very very
important
we know that attention works so the the
huge Iranian cyber um army they have a
huge Army cyber army they spread out
every day and what the amongst other
things what they do is that they look
which name
which prisoner's name is floating out
there
is that prisoner getting attention do
people protect them if this prisoner is
named if we have pictures of this
prisoner then
it is more likely for him to be treated
better and to survive
so sponsors sponsorships are very very
important attention is very important to
name the crimes because the lack of
accountability that we've talked about
before
is crucial
for these people in in in in the regime
and also
um
this regime is not North Korea so
because there has been a very long
tradition of people and also inside the
regime traveling to the west to North
America to Europe because they have
Family Ties they have friends who live
you know Iranians you know that live all
all around the world
and so the regime itself will never cut
ties like for instance North Korea so
this is where
the European Union has an angle they
want to keep up ties they do go to
Russia they do go to China because they
have to because they will not survive
without these two countries
but it is important to not underestimate
the effect that the European Union can
have and at the same time I want to say
that and I I mentioned that and
um that it is not and I think you you
know that of course but it is not the
the task of the West to teach other
countries democracy and you know like
and explore democracy we saw that in in
Iraq that it it goes horribly wrong and
in Afghanistan
because these people know themselves
they don't need to learn anything they
know sometimes even better than us when
I look at
at right right-wing parties in in you
know all across Europe and also in the
European Parliament
so I think what's important is when we
look at the
dictatorships all around the world
authoritarian regimes in the global
South in general
you mentioned uh Brazil or South Africa
that is that we need to
deal with them not in a way that you
know we give you something and then you
give us something back but in a way that
we are aware that we live in a world
that is intertwined that is
interdependent
and I think Europe has not understood
that yet I see that in the media I see
that in politics and I think if we get
to a point where this is more
um
understanding of that we are connected
and not only because we're scared of
refugees but because we know that we
will only be free if everyone is free
then I think this whole dynamic between
the global North and the global South
will change
um and I think that's about the
discourse Iranian address at diaspora
so
uh it's a
I think some of you probably have have
experienced that yourselves maybe that
it's they are not exactly very United
um and still what I've seen at least in
Germany and I think in many states in
Europe is that incredibly just
incredible many many activists have done
have been doing incredible work
they have founded woman life Freedom
collectives all around the the continent
and I think just to give them a platform
to let them speak to let them be the
voice of the people in Iran I think that
is very very important because as I said
attention and the Islamic Republic is a
very special case when it comes to that
it doesn't work with this with Russia
for instance but with the Iranian regime
yes they want to commit their crimes in
darkness and once we shed light they are
seen and that changes things
and then you ask about unions that is
also very very very important because of
course unions are forbidden in the
Islamic Republic
but they exist and they are very
um agile they uh they organize strikes
they've been doing that for years and
the the question of General strikes is
very very important we had for the first
time in history in the history of the
Islamic Republic we had a general strike
all across the country all across the
country in the beginning of December
that never happened before
and of course the problem are sanctions
because these people need money to be
able to strike but we cannot give money
to Iran
so we have the issue of a lot a lot of
sanctions that in the end punish the
people and way too few sanctions that
punish the people who are committing
crimes so there's just a disbalance that
needs to be fixed and again of course
these are the member states that have to
do that
um
people leaving the country uh very few
indeed um so I've talked to people
who've been in prison in the last year
and they said they told me once I got
out of prison I want to leave the
country less because
they that that's the the coming together
that I mentioned they want to support
one another they don't want to leave and
at the same time it is very very
important that we do help people who
want to leave when you have to leave
because they are threatened their lives
are threatened their family's life are
threatened I have had a few cases myself
that I gave to members of parliament in
Germany if you have any chance to help
please do because they are in in danger
they do need to get out it's a minority
there isn't there I don't think there
will ever be a flood of refugees from
Iran
it's just not something that they want
to do because from what I've observed
they want to stay and they want to be
free in their own country
and just to end with how is it going to
go on
um as I mentioned I think that people
are going to
wait until the regime
does not expect more protests because
they were expecting it for their
anniversary anniversary and that's why
people try to protest but it was just
impossible friend of mine and this one
told me it's just it's like a war zone
there's no way of walking even around
I'm convinced that this regime is going
to fall
I have no idea how long it's going to
take I think it is absolutely impossible
for a government to only govern with
violence forever
I think it's impossible for a government
to to govern against 85 to 90 people of
their population
and yet excuse me they have all the
weapons they have all the power and so
they will kill until their last breaths
and it is I think it is going to take
longer than we would hope for and
certainly the Iranian people would hope
for
thank you so so much Gilda for this Rich
conversation I will now invite uh asada
Kian to join us for the last round but
Gilda if you would like to stay in this
conversation we appreciate in any case
we would like to stay in touch uh I
could say that for all the colleagues
here in the human rights subcommittee of
the European Parliament there will be
occasions to continue our conversation
welcome
sociologist and expert on Iran and
women's rights University Parisi day you
have to flaw for some eight minutes
can we support her
yeah
let me give the floor again to uh asada
Kian
from the University of Paris Paris City
can you hear us
can you see us
unfortunately there is no direct
connection what can we do
let me ask
our
technicians how can we support our
speaker
pardon
do it please yes
collects some patients we have technical
problems
I can hear now
are you with us now
yes
could you say something
yes hi um good afternoon perfect we are
waiting for your contribution thanks for
being with us today
uh and you have heard we are on the
situation in Iran we are on the
situation one year after
the murder
that has shaken
the Iranian society and the whole world
please address us and then we enter into
a discussion
yes
I uh sorry I had a conference here and
couldn't hear uh uh javidrahman and only
parts of Kinder sahibi's answers to our
questions but I very much agree with her
uh so let me just Begin by saying that
maybe I should speak in French for a
change
um that
um
last year the I'm afraid the sound is
cutting in and out the movement started
last year with the murder of Masha amini
I'm afraid the sound is cutting in and
out
movement
the family
minorities
wait one second because we lost the
translation for those colleagues who are
not able to follow in French
is it perhaps an idea
no then we do not have any translation
if you if you shut down the pictures can
we do anything on the visual connection
because as I said at the beginning of
our meeting our interpreters are not
able to translate anything but they do
not have uh the picks properly uh
suitable to read also the lips uh
can we do and work something on that
otherwise we decide to follow in French
could make so that we get you
just a second just a second
so colleagues the technical information
is that we are not able to restore
picture and sound so the decision is
that we invite our guests to continue in
French
knowing that our interpreters will not
be able to give us a translation so we
leave it in the French original language
those who are happy with that are able
then to comment and to communicate but
we have to close anyhow in some 15
minutes so let us finalize that as good
as we can
and thank already azadequian for being
with Us Against All Odds Against All
technical problems that we would like to
overcome
okay
um
particularly questions
[Music]
political Encore consideration
majority population uh
you will see this is
um
design
foreign
Mercy
[Music]
many thanks for your energy that you
were staying with us
against all technical problems uh we
heard you and we heard that you have
confirmed the observations of Gilda
sahibi but you also raised the question
how can we more and more put pressure on
the regime by using our economic
relations by using our political and
diplomatic influence and by also not
only working on the European
institutions but also on the framework
of the United Nations
to come to consequences for the regime
to by doing so also to enlarge the space
of freedom and the conditions for the
fight in Iran we also know that you have
to rush forward
because you have uh to catch a train
so I would like to ask my colleagues to
be very very brief but now I see is the
first colleague who would like to raise
a common uh question
English
[Music]
good afternoon well I've got a comment
and a question
my comment is that including during the
Cold War
when Western countries were putting huge
pressure on communist countries not just
the USSR but also Central Europe
well it never came down to external
pressure to get rid of these regimes and
bring them down
it was the social movements within these
countries and the brutal degradation of
the economic situation with regard to
the USSR
they brought it to its end
now on to my question when we see photos
of the streets of Tehran today
it appears quite frequent to see young
women or indeed women of any age to be
walking along the street without a
headscarf on
now as far as you're aware
are there many women who do this
and what happens to them if they make
this choice
are they arrested are they harassed or
both
could you tell us a little bit more
about that
if an eye on your timetable we leave it
like that and hope you have still a
couple of minutes to respond to our vice
president bernardgeta
the floss years well thank you very much
um uh merci
beaucoupons
is regulations
Supreme
effective foreign
political
[Music]
for being with us today and all the best
for your work also we would like to stay
in touch with you unfortunately we think
the issue is not leaving us tomorrow
morning so that we have to continue in
our dialogue all the best and and thanks
for being with us again let me bring in
the external Action Service
that I got to know is Mr Romano if that
is correct correct uh wonderful
no mistake so far please take the four
for a couple of minutes we are under
time pressure but you have realized how
often
the institutional dimension of our
politics was concerned and these
conversations over we are Keen hearing
from you or to take of the external
action services
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
everyone
let me start by thanking the parliament
for the stock taking moment the killing
of massage in amini indeed was a major
turning point it was a turning point
for civil society in Iran and it was a
turning point
for the EU in terms of policy approach
towards Iran
these days last year we saw Brave
Iranian women and men demanding respect
for their fundamental aspirations
and we also saw
what the Iranian response was
a violent and unjustifiable repression
today the situation the ground remains
difficult
we don't see much protest activities and
this is due to a combination of factors
a lack of proper coordination
lack of political support from within
the system contrary to what happened in
2009 with the Grim movement
an absence of a visible leadership and I
think this was
summarized very well by Professor Kian
when she said
in alternative politics
but then we should also mention other
factors we should mention mass arrest
arbitrary detentions are sentences
including the use of capital punishment
the EU and its member states have
responded with a series of strong and
concrete reactions to the violent
Crackdown in Iran and the shrinking
space for civil society
we have new kinds of conclusions
toughening the new position
with Iran on all fronts and especially
on the human rights front
we've issued strong statements and we
have adopted 10 rounds of sanctions
the last one was adopted precisely on
the first anniversary of the killing of
masamine in parallel the hrvp issued a
strong statement on behalf of the 27.
to reconfirm the EU strong support for
desperations of the Iranian people
in this context I also would like to
mention
the strong support of the EU for even
mechanism for accountability for human
rights violations in Iran
in this contest
we support in full the Mandate of
Professor rechman who was with us today
as the hrbps said on many occasion
view will continue to use its diplomatic
Channels with Iran and will continue to
use all other options at its disposal
including restrictive measures meaning
sanctions to push for tangible
improvements in the human rights
situation in Iran
this approach supported by all member
states is to be seen in the context of
our policy of critical engagement with
Iran outlined in the council conclusion
adopted last year in December
thank you for your attention is to
appear
thank you for being with us and and
leaving us with this comment
um
be assured that the European Parliament
will continue to be engaged with the
situation Iran and also
we are part of the same debate I think
you can feel
that members of parliament not only our
guests but also members of parliament
feel impatient about
but our guests called the reaction of
the best
and that we are urging institutions
especially Our member states
to be more tough
and to commit themselves for rigid and
challenging reaction on the regime
and that we do not find our peace with a
status quo situation where people are
suffering
people who are fighting for their
Justified demands for freedom and
democracy thanks for being with us also
we are going to stay in touch and
continue our dialogue I would like now
to go and move forward to our last point
on the agenda today
which is also a very very
saddening development on which we have
to become active and to highlight the
circumstances that is the exchange of
views on the human rights situation of
Ethiopian migrants at the game in Saudi
border
in the presence of Nadia hatman I hope
that Nadia is connected with Usman
researcher in the refugee and migrants
rights division of Human Rights
watch Human Rights Watch of course
who is in charge of this file
and also was coordinating a report
released in August of Human Rights Watch
a report with shed light on the E human
situation migrants faced and the mass
killing of Ethiopian migrants
at the Yemen Saudi borders between March
22 and June 23 from here expertise we
got to know that killings have been
organized now for quite a while it
started in 2014 but now we have a new
cumulation